hi there Steve here I'm halfway through
my 90 day challenge and today I hit
forty thousand new words that was my
goal my goal is to reach 50,000 but I
wanted to reach 40,000 about halfway
through and I have reached it mostly by
working my way through new content but
recently I've been going through the old
content because i have 38,000 saved
links and if i can convert even 10,000
of those into known words i'll be
reaching my 50,000 level and as a reward
I went to a Korean restaurant today and
it took a picture I tried to speak
Korean to the waiter and they answered
in English oh you speak Korean very well
couldn't get them to speak to me in
Korean everything was in English this
happens I want to talk to you about the
Montreal language festival I had a
fabulous time last year and it's
happening again in August I'm putting a
link up here in my description box it's
the 25th to the 27th in Montreal at
Concordia University it's the Montreal
language festival you gotta go there
you'll meet so many people who are
interested in languages and people come
from far away different parts of the US
we had people from Latin America we had
I guess people from other parts of the
world who are living in North America
and all of them keen on languages all of
them full of hints tips advice
interesting presentations Montreal's a
great city picnicking in the park lafont
em the whole thing is well worth it ok
it's an opportunity to get into touch
with languages from around the world
broaden your horizon I want to I'm going
of course and I hope to see you there so
please click on the link come to the
Montreal language festival bye for now